[Musica]
Io sono qui per raccontarvi una Inter
reazione molto particolare ovvero
l'impatto con la mia morte non è usuale
che qualcuno torni per raccontarle è
successo
1990 anni fa
ed è risuccesso in maniera molto meno
Nobile molto meno storica e più
particolare Io sono stato al mio
funerale e tornando Ho imparato alcune
cose non tanto sulla morte quanto sulla
vita il funerale si è svolto in Corea
del Sud dove una multinazionale
Cercava un sistema per aumentare
l'attaccamento alla vita dei suoi
dipendenti è una società di psicologi ha
detto non c'è altra cosa migliore che fa
di sperimentare Che cosa vuol dire non
averla più quella vita e quindi
celebriamo il funerale e io ho chiesto
di poter partecipare a questa esperienza
che ho svolto singolarmente volte che
cosa è accaduto la prima cosa è stata
che mi è stato chiesto di fare
testamento
cosa che nessuno fa mai con tanto
entusiasmo anche solo per ragioni
scaramantiche in una stanza illuminata
da una luce di candela con un foglio una
penna ho cercato di pensare Quali erano
le persone a cui volevo destinare le
cose quali erano queste cose e vi lancio
uno spoiler pochissime nel caso e
nell'altro E quella era un primo indizio
dell'essenzialità che la vita poi sono
sceso al piano di sotto dove mi
attendeva un inserviente davanti
alla bara e mi ha dato un accappatoio
senza tasche mi ha detto indossa questo
perché è noto che nella vita noi
arriviamo senza niente e senza niente ce
ne andiamo e quindi quello era l'unico
indumento adatto a rappresentare la
situazione dopodiché sono entrato nella
barra mi sono sdraiato
e qualcuno ha battuto sui chiodi
buio
per un tempo che non saprò mai perché
non ho potuto cronometrarlo ma immagino
non sia stato molto simile ai 15 minuti
e 37 36 35 che mi stanno scorrendo
davanti in quei minuti non potevo far
altro che pensare
e siccome gli umani al netto dei grandi
e piccoli filosofi affrontano i temi
della vita molto raramente solo quando
si imbattono in un trauma forse a volte
c'era bisogno di un trauma inscenato che
si affrontasse Qualcosa che veramente
conta nella vita perché io imparassi e
cercarsi poi di divulgare alcune cose di
tutte fondamentali Quali cose
avevo da raccontare una volta uscito da
quella bara La prima è che non è vero
che tutta la vita ti scorre davanti
quando stai finendo in due minuti vedi
gli highlights Come in una partita le
azioni principali le cose più importanti
più devastanti che hai fatto pensateci
bene Vi si spegne il televisore mentre
state seguendo la vostra serie preferita
e qualcuno vi dice potete vedere ancora
tre minuti cosa fareste vedere il
riassunto delle puntate precedenti o tre
minuti della puntata che non ho ancora
visto
E allora perché passiamo tanto tempo
della vita a ricordare a fare bilanci
invece che a progettare e poi quando
ricordiamo e facciamo bilanci mettiamo
il segno più il segno meno e trucchiamo
inevitabilmente Cerchiamo di rendere più
positivo quello che positivo Non è stato
per accettare la vita che abbiamo avuto
male la vita che abbiamo avuto va
accettata per scindere dai segni importa
quello che possiamo fare da adesso in
avanti per cambiarla e poi ho guardato
questo vestito senza tasche e mi sono
chiesto Ma allora perché se con niente
arriviamo e con niente ce ne andiamo
perché per tutto il tragitto per questo
viaggio che è la vita ci carichiamo di
pesi perché accumuliamo cose perché
viaggiamo con queste grandi sgomento
quando negli aeroporti vedo queste coi
grandi religioni perché penso questi
hanno voluto mettere dentro tutto perché
potessero rispondere a tutte le
variabili mi porto vestiti lunghi
vestiti corti pesanti leggeri perché non
so che tempo farà mi porto delle
medicine in caso tu non sai mai Che
tempo farà non saprai mai di che cosa ti
ammalerai stai cercando di giocare una
partita che è persa in partenza con
l'imprevedibile che è il destino allora
viaggia col bagaglio a mano viaggia con
quei piccoli trolley O meglio ancora con
lo zainetto perché il bagaglio a mano è
il simbolo perfetto perché ha l'ingombro
prestabilito il peso limitato e uno
pensa regole regole
No sono regole nelle quali tu entri per
vivere nella maniera migliore perché
nella valigia entra quello che ci sta
nella gagliaglio a mano entra quello che
tu vuoi Quello che ti servirà quello che
è
indispensabile quello che è essenziale e
invece noi ci carichiamo di cose ma
soprattutto di cose immateriali di pesi
che apparentemente non pesano nulla ma
pesano tantissimo e il più grande di
questi è il tentativo di portare una
seconda vita una vita di scorta perché
quella che abbiamo non ci soddisfa fino
in fondo e allora A volte cerchiamo di
viverne due contemporaneamente
producendo dei disastri fatali sono due
esempi nella storia recente uno dei
kamikaze dell'11 settembre che il 10
settembre fa il testamento rituale
davanti alla telecamera finisce prende
il telefono chiama la moglie e dice
abbiamo organizzato la festa di
matrimonio in Libano tra una settimana
delle due l'una o muori domani o hai una
festa tra una settimana e il maggiore
Parolisi forse lo ricorderete che aveva
la moglie è un amante arriva al punto in
questa sua bigamia e la vita Big ma non
lo è mai arriva al punto di prenotare
per la stessa Pasqua vacanze in montagna
con la moglie e al mare con l'amante
spoiler sono finiti tutti e due molto
male ma soprattutto sono finite male le
persone accanto a loro perché chi vive
in questa maniera diventa pericoloso ma
lo diventiamo un po' tutti si facciamo a
fregare da quel piccolo mito narrativo
che la Sliding Door l'altra Porta quella
che non abbiamo preso ora Io oggi sono
venuto qui
avrei potuto andare a giocare un torneo
di tennis nella mia visione domani
penserò che se fossi andato Sicuramente
avrei vinto perché la slide indoor è
sempre questo è l'idea che la porta che
non abbiamo preso ci avrebbe aperto una
vita migliore fantastica illusione la
vita è quello che si compone lentamente
quella che ci scegliamo e se ho scelto
di venire qui Questa è la scelta da cui
costruire la vita qui in avanti senza
guardarsi indietro senza rimpiangere
l'opportunità che non c'è stata perché
il fantasma delle vite non vissute e uno
dei nostri peggiori nemici Cioè in molti
quasi tutti ma Anch'io l'ho portato
dentro con me per tempo Il fantasma
della professione che non ho scelto del
di quello che sarei diventato se avessi
fatto un'altra cosa Ma questo vivendo
con noi giorno dopo giorno Erode l'unica
vita che abbiamo perché continuiamo a
pensare a una vita che non c'è stata che
in fondo non era possibile e che
probabilmente sarebbe stata anche meno
felice di questa e quindi va abbandonato
va lasciato al suo destino perché
altrimenti
continuando a tenere dentro di noi
questo estraneo che non entrerà mai
nella barra finale perché sarà andato
nel suo mondo nulla noi diventeremo
nemici delle persone che abbiamo vicino
perché diremo non è andata così per
colpa dei miei genitori erano andata
così per colpa di mio marito di mia
moglie non è andata così perché ho fatto
dei figli o peggio ancora diremo non è
andata così per colpa mia
e individueremo il nemico in noi stessi
e quindi la vita non è Big ma ce n'è una
non c'è scorta si può
Strada facendo
aggiungere cambiare la vita che abbiamo
così come dentro lo zaino si può mettere
la daffle bag quella che si Ripiega e al
ritorno se ce n'è bisogno estrarre
viaggiare con un piccolo bagaglio in più
oppure può capitare perché nella vita
questo succede di perderlo il bagaglio
parte del suo contenuto e di questo sì
che abbiamo paura altri che della luce
che si spegne perché perdere in tutte le
sue possibili declinazioni è un verbo
che spaventa abbiamo paura della
sconfitta perdere abbiamo paura di
smarrirci perderci in americano
Addirittura il perdente il loser e la
definizione peggiore che si possa dare
di qualcuno tu vuoi essere tutto ma non
un Loser
Ma la vita è fatta di perderti a volte
lo stand Found dovrebbe essere corretto
con Lost is Found una volta incontrato
Tony Willer che il fondatore della
Lonely Planet cioè le guide che ti
insegnano a viaggiare del pianeta e
mentre cenavamo avete Ma sai che in
realtà in luoghi più belli e più
interessanti di questo pianeta li ho
trovati quando mi sono perduto
perdere più il piano B La dafall bag più
aver perso il bagaglio principale può
portarti verso un destino migliore una
volta ho incontrato un uomo di nome Niki
brillante
era lo stesso cognome della delle grandi
direttrici di Voghera al suo nipote e da
ragazzo voleva fare il fotografo di moda
sarà sandillo e ovviamente
è stata alzata il telefono è stato
chiamato Irving pen grande fotografo lui
è andato a studio del rimpani a 18 anni
era già una affermato fotografo poi mi
hanno rubato tutte le macchine
fotografiche ha perso tutta la sua
attrezzatura a quel punto anziché
immediatamente compare un'altra con i
soldi dell'assicurazione Ha detto vabbè
intanto mi giro il mondo per un anno e
mentre girava il mondo gli è cresciuta
sempre più dentro la dafall bag il piano
B la seconda vocazione quella spirituale
è diventato un monaco il primo Abate in
un monastero buddista in Oriente che sia
nato in Occidente piano B più perdita
uguale felicità a volte altra paura di
cui abbiamo il terrore senza
fare senza preoccupante Tutti i composti
sono negativi in tutte le lingue del
mondo senzatetto santapiede Homeless
sono tutte condizioni perdenti invece
fare senza può essere improvvisa
arricchita soprattutto che quello che
abbiamo in più lo doniamo a qualcuno
viene a meno e in questo modo noi
Procederemo più leggeri nel viaggio
qualcun altro possa fare un po' di
strada in più perché
c'è strada da fare Ci sono situazioni da
affrontare e affrontare con la
leggerezza e avendo fatto una scelta che
ti tiene accanto le cose fondamentali Ma
come le riconosciamo
li riconosciamo Sì se non facciamo
l'errore di pensare che accumulando
prima o poi ci sia quella giusta perché
c'è una una frase una scena che a me
torna spesso in mente l'autore di comma
22 Joseph heller si trovava un giorno a
un ricevimento in una villa Long Island
dato da un multi milionario e un amico
mentre passeggiava ma con il drink in
mano gli chiese Ma a te che effetto fa
pensare che questo che ci ospita ieri
soltanto ieri ha guadagnato più di
quanto tu guadagnerai tutta la tua vita
con i proventi di questo tuo romanzo di
grande successo
heller si fermò e disse Io sai ho
qualcosa che lui non avrà mai Che cos'è
gli chiese l'amico risposto la
consapevolezza di avere abbastanza
capire che cosa significa abbastanza è
il punto di arrivo smettendo a un certo
punto di aumentare il possesso Perché
chi possiede fa del male anche a te di
smettere soprattutto non farti possedere
da qualcuno
limitato
di cose di esperienze anche diceva il
poeta carrapis non portare troppo in
giro la tua vita fino a fare una
stucchevole estranea non accettare tutti
gli inviti non partecipare a tutto non
apparire dovunque scegli scegliere
fondamentale ma quando bisogna scegliere
c'è un termine sempre usati in America
che quello della Bucket list la lista
del secchio cioè le cose da fare prima
di morire le città che vuoi vedere
l'esperienza che non puoi mancare i
libri che devi leggere ecco Ma quand'è
che devi farlo ora sono in molti a dire
adesso ma lo dicono quando gli sta
accadendo il trauma e invece vi dico no
non dovete fatelo proprio adesso adesso
che state bene adesso che potete
scegliere tra infinite possibilità
adesso che siete giovani adesso che
nessun futuro è scritto ma non sapete
quanto lungo sarà questo futuro per cui
prima lo compilate questa lista e prima
è meglio è
perché il tempo è una variabile che non
può mai essere controllata e quindi non
aspettate il trauma Piuttosto allora
un giorno qualsiasi chiudetevi una
stanza molto stretta e noi ripostiglio
Spegnete la luce e lì pensate a chi
vorreste Davvero
E ci entri in quel piccolo spazio con
voi e a Quali cose starebbero su tre
scaffali
vorreste con voi quando uscite Quando
riaprite la porta nella vostra casa
illuminata tenetene conto perché
Ricordatelo che non vi sarà mai lieve la
terra gli Stelliere la vita
[Applauso]
[Musica]